agents picked up four migrants since
october whose names are on the terror
watch list and that's according to a
congressional aide
familiar with the information let's
bring in texas congressman dan crenshaw
congressman i'm assuming that obviously
this is something that you're paying
close attention to what do you know hey
thanks for having me on dana yeah
you know that's just the ones we've
caught and the democrats got fact
checked pretty quickly on that after
kevin mccarthy
claimed that and it was confirmed by
press reports
by the way we just learned that the
biden administration is telling border
patrol
not to allow ride-alongs from the press
so they really don't want this this
truth getting out
here's the thing when you have hundreds
and hundreds of people uh paying the
drug cartels a piece of about 300
per person they get to cross the river
and then they tie up border patrol's
hands they're bringing children with
them they're bringing unaccompanied
minors
in border patrol instead of patrolling
the border well they become babysitters
they become bus drivers they become
nurses
and you know what they're not doing
they're not looking for those people on
a terrorist watch list that are going in
between right there's a distraction over
here
and the bad guys who don't want to get
caught come through over here so that's
just a fraction of what's
going through there's a real crisis on
the border the buddhist administration
would admit it
and they created it by executive orders
uh rescinding trump's policies that were
actually working
however the head of dhs just yesterday
said the border's secure
what would you say to him well they're
lying and we have an unprecedented
crisis look in the past month we're
looking at about a
hundred thousand people crossing per
month and by the way that adds up to
about 30 million dollars
in the drug cartels pockets when you
calculate how much it costs for
one person to go across the binding
administration is literally funding the
mexican drug cartels you know what they
call this they call this compassion
they call this a humane border policy
but there's nothing humane or
compassionate about funding drug cartels
there's nothing compassionate about
incentivizing people
to to throw kids across the border to to
engage in human smuggling
and there's nothing compassionate about
cutting in front of millions of people
around the world
who are trying to use our system legally
get a visa here claim asylum
here because they actually have a valid
claim to asylum but instead we're
allowing people of a geographical
advantage to take advantage of the
system
and clog it up and it's it's not moral
it's not fair to legal immigrants and
it's certainly not compassionate and it
must stop
congressman let me show you this so this
is new information 561 unaccompanied
miners were taken into custody on monday
that's up 60 from the daily average in
february
um there of course in dallas they're
going to use a convention center to
house some of these
you know i think when you go back to
compassion and the worries
look you you can't imagine what it's
like for some of them like
obviously feeling alone maybe even
abandoned by their parents or missing
their parents or
and then the parents who are saying go
try to save yourself and the
administration
they're scrambling yeah and you know why
they're telling them to go
because they're look they're doing a
rational economic cost benefit analysis
if it's going to be slightly better here
then they're just going to send their
kid across maybe there's an uncle maybe
there's
a family member somewhere in the u.s
probably here illegally also
that they're hoping that that
unaccompanied minor will get to
now now the gaslighting going on in this
administration
is is really infuriating uh jen sackey
said i think yesterday
well you know we're dealing with a
broken system passed on by the net by
the last administration of course this
is a full-blown lie
that this happened overnight okay when
when president biden rescinded the
remaining mexico policy when they
rescinded the asylum cooperation
agreements with the northern triangle
countries
when they said hey we're not going to
deport you when you come so
so biden has the nerve to say quietly
hey don't come
wink don't come don't come here
don't come here if you come here we're
going to give you a bus ticket wherever
you want and we're not going to deport
you don't come here
that's what he's doing is that it's
absolutely gaslighting the clip that we
just played from abc
exactly that's exactly right it's like
it's like something's coming out of his
mouth but he's saying something
completely different with his actions
some of the migrants are telling
reporters those who get access and the
access have been limited too frankly
based on some of the reports we get from
our colleagues like griff jenkins
that they're watching on television as
miners make it across the border and
they say hey
if they can go for it we're going to go
too so those images create an impression
that it's wide open yeah
that's a because it is wide open look
under under trump you had the remaining
mexico policy which said look if you're
claiming asylum
fine we'll adjudicate it but you have to
remain in mexico city while we do it you
don't just get to be released into the
interior never to show up for your
deportation hearing when it finally
comes around
because look only about 10 of these
asylum claims
end up being adjudicated in a positive
manner meaning meaning that they're
truly being
persecuted look the reality is is most
the vast majority of people are economic
migrants they're making
a simple cost-benefit decision okay if
it's slightly better here well then i'll
go
and if joe biden says that i can come
and be released into the interior and
you know get my covid test get some
health care
and get a bus ticket wherever i want and
not get deported and they're working on
legislation to give me amnesty
well that seems like a pretty good deal
they're telling me not to come but i
feel like they're winking
at me and telling me to come and they do